for just the fourth time since the
election president trump appeared in
public and again falsely claimed that he
won the 2020
election friday's claim was his latest
attempt to challenge the results
of president-elect joe biden's victory
also on friday mr trump met with
michigan legislators at the white house
in hopes of potentially overturning that
state's results
and he learned that biden's win was
certified after a hand recount in
georgia chip reid is in washington this
morning with the latest on all of this
chef good morning
well good morning president trump is
having very little success in his
desperate attempts to overturn the
results of the 2020 election but
he is still showing no signs of
conceding anytime
soon i won by the way but you know we'll
find that out
almost 74 million votes in just his
fourth public appearance since the
election president trump
pressed on we had big pharma against us
we had
the media against us we had big tech
against us
mr trump also met with two republican
michigan lawmakers at the white house
to discuss the election results in the
wolverine state
but both agreed there is no path to
victory for the president
in a statement they said michigan's
certification process should be a
deliberate process free from threats and
intimidation adding the candidates who
win the most votes win elections
and michigan's electoral votes and late
last night michigan's naacp
sued president trump for the campaign's
attempts to disenfranchise
black voters i believe that the numbers
that we have presented today are correct
down south president-elect joe biden
won georgia's recount and solidified
that state's
16 electoral votes further weakening
president trump's path to an election
reversal
intelligence committee chairman adam
schiff was critical of his republican
colleagues who seem
wary of challenging the president's
refusal to concede
if they don't put an end to it now they
will never find the courage to stand up
to him
they will never reclaim their party
meanwhile the administration's confirmed
coronavirus cases continue
to grow rudy giuliani's son andrew a top
white house aide with close contact to
the president
and at least four other aides tested
positive for covid19 this week
donald trump jr tested positive for
kovid too
with the rise in cases this fall dr
anthony fauci warns americans to be
cautious over the thanksgiving holiday
pause for a moment and do a
determination
of the risk benefit within your family
group
and then when you make your decision
that's your decision
no one's forcing anything on you
president trump participates in a
virtual g20 summit at the white house
this morning
also cbs news has learned that the
president has expressed interest in
meeting with pennsylvania state
legislators at the white house too
president-elect biden's victory in his
home state solidified the projected
victory
mr biden has the st but the state has
until monday to certify
their vote totals dana all right chip no
slow down at the holidays thank you